we have a jodas on Oh on the funnest am
i pronouncing your name correctly sir
joe cassano and let me just say guys I'm
a fan oh yeah how I'm seeing it Keenum
live saw him on the virus tour and 0 5
rows sex that's amazing well she'll go
so what you guys Jim when you don't know
about Joe is you're a fan of Joe's to he
is the advisor who saw our mayor dancing
around compochia on board that now that
was yeah we at least we tweeted an
article that you were quoted in that you
had seen him dancing around like a
monkey and using the n-word that true oh
it's absolutely true um and I wasn't uh
you know how was an advisor of his from
03 to about 13 mm-hmm and finally the
final straw was uh you know the guys got
a lot of problems let's let's be friends
mom but the final straw was him dancing
around like a monkey and and I'm not
going to lie there were financial
problems too he had made promises that
he involved through on and you know I
don't get a paycheck every two weeks so
um you know at some point if you don't
pay I don't work and then when you we
just dive into the racial well like this
you know enough is enough so what did
you think he was also dating his
assistant oh yeah absolutely was yeah
there's no okay we were giving him the
benefit of a doubt figure these tapes
were out of context and there was an
impressionist right the vocals so that's
probably not true no no rich little was
not on the teeth maybe boss so wait he
gave is assistant arrays while you were
were you looking for to get your money
and she got a raise uh well yeah I mean
I was never a city employee I was you
know I was a private consultant okay but
now here's the interesting story one of
the situations that led to eat just say
enough is enough was um he was taped in
Chicago by a private investigator
walking along michigan avenue kissing
the assistants and um holding her hand
as they walk uh-huh
and um I got wind of the tape because
basically political people are scumbags
I got you know wind that the tape
existed and I thought I had a duty to at
least up alert him to the possibility
that this tape existed so I went to his
office and I said there you got a
problem there's rumors out there of a
tape of you and Amanda your girlfriend
are walking along michigan avenue making
out and he denied it but it's not me I'm
not a secretary for any point why would
he cannot really a lot you know it was a
rumor and I you know I gave him my best
advice as consultants saying look
there's a good chance this exists you've
got to have some type of response arm
and he just denied it which is fine you
know what that's your business but where
the story gets weird is when the local
ABC affiliate a couple months down the
road actually get the tape mm-hmm arm he
accuses me of being part of the
conspiracy what Wow yeah this is how
nuts this guy is and it's gotten
progressively worse over the years how
long is even layin for them he's been
there since 2009 and I began working
with him when he goes on the City
Council in okla we he was on the council
for 30 years okay but I first started
working with him in the 02 03 period so
what context would he use the n-word in
when you were in meeting Oh quickie well
it's quite casual him right um it's kind
of like hanging around Anthony be fun
like Anthony know Anthony's a fun guy no
no no no no no no no mister mr. Anthony
has the ability to be funny this man has
no sense of humor so he's not kidding
anyways after he does this guy just just
have a rude sense of humor he like means
it yeah these tapes are up are pure look
into a man's dark heart around whatever
happens is in there um
I mean there's a whole bunch of ethical
problems mean basically she runs the
city in my opinion because she could she
could you know suit him at any point for
harassment correct dose you know there's
a huge profit um that has been
underreported in my mind what what he
had some the ethical minefield what what
do you think who do you think recorded
him like because these the audio is so
clear it has to be in the room there's
no almost no background sounds like a
studio how do you think he got recorded
from well but it's getting one everyone
record them there are more tapes out
there oh damn yeah there's everyone
record everyone just had me running tape
on him wherever he goes it still just
runs all over the mouth I'm assuming
that he records everything he's very nic
Sonia okay i had so i'm assuming that
when i go into the room i'm being taped
so I tape as well Wow but the point the
point being is this everyone's keeping
him because no one trusts it okay right
because they very raising them they're
going to really he's going to release a
tape of them so they have to tape him so
that way it's not out of kind of find
yourself yeah do you think is possibly
that somebody got a hold of this guy's
own tape so get on Nixon's tapes did in
no no no no um what it is is the the
first batch it tastes that were released
before Christmas I know who did the tape
okay okay I know who did it and released
it no in SA we see the first batch of
tapes you're referring to the tapes in
which he refers to people that are
mentally challenged as useless and talks
about them living in cages crepes now I
have to be very fair I've never heard
him say anything like that right oh that
was kind of like a gut punch one that
you never heard him say stuff about
[ __ ] people it was more you heard
the wrinkles up not that not he said you
never heard him ponder about how people
who are mentally challenged use the
bathroom no I probably would have sort
of throwing fists at that point okay
okay now do you know who released the
tape are you able to say
who was it release it I can't okay I can
um mostly because he he is in a position
where his job would be flatness his name
came up okay but but the racial stuff
when you hear the tapes that came out
yesterday the Rays of stuff that sounds
like exactly like the type of stuff you
would hear in any given out yeah I would
go so far as to even say I think it may
have been estate it may have been a tape
of a meeting I was in Wow yes yeah it's
quite possible because I he was very
casual particularly with the story about
the 2n words in the party store right
right what he's a kid that anecdote yeah
I've heard him tell that antidote a
number so is he and he's giving up an
age so he doesn't remember when he says
they how old a guy is he wheelies I
guess cuz I'm 1107 here for before and
how old was it heaters she's uh probably
about 30 now but here's the interesting
thing so he has another scandal couple
years ago where he lied about his age
what okay oh no yeah he shaped like five
or six years off his age so that quote
unquote and this is this is like in the
newspaper if you dig deep enough so he
doing dig deep enough Google search on
him so he can date younger women so is
he a single guy yeah I'd never married
so how does how does a guy like this who
appears to be somewhat of a monster get
elected mayor like it doesn't sound like
all these scandals just sort of popped
up or all these behaviors just started
happening since 2009 it sounds like yeah
a lot of this has been going on since he
was on city council would he run against
jared fogle uh not not too far from the
not too far from the truth actually he
got like eighty five percent in the last
election oh my god what you have to keep
in mind is when he was on the City
Council he never brought any scrutiny he
was just one of several members okay and
since he's a single guy with no family
he's able to handle every incoming
problem and deal with it in a very
personal way okay which is good politics
I mean if you essentially all politics
is about building a relationship with
voters or in most cases a fake
relationship with voters yeah um he was
able to do that because like literally
he would sit home at night and take
every phone call and every every um you
know where question someone for help he
drank in that perspective he's a good
city was a good um a good public servant
do do you think we guessed about it Joey
like oh I I believe him to be complete
non drinker okay wow so he's saying this
stuff you clear-headed what do you do
when you're sitting there you're like my
job is to advise this guy I'm a
political advisor and you're watching
the mayor that you have to advise in
front of a board room to see you around
like a chimpanzee to describe his voters
like what goes on in your head well
those aren't you see here's the thing
that's not his voters oh yeah his City
straddle eight mile which you'll
remember from the M&M movie right vomit
on edge whether already mom's spaghetti
yeah so um his city is is the South
border of the city is eight mile and now
you're starting to see african-american
voters cross the border in them into arm
into worid arm but they're at this point
in time they're not really great voters
I think haven't been it yeah it you got
a changing city okay and you got a mayor
who's like literally walking off the set
of madmen madmen right old school
although you even raised this for old
school yeah I mean I sleeve I mean the
ability to not know you're you're saying
these things in front of people who are
going to say something back and then
people didn't really talk about stuff
but you can't say [ __ ] like this in
front of people now there could have
been you're gonna keep it quiet there
could have been fire elf is on the
street people would still be like mayor
relax I Jesus mayor you can though if
you're surrounded by people who make
six-figure salaries completely based on
your whim right you know you do develop
a cocoon
yeah and then and then it all just falls
away at one point all you can do is sit
there and be like knots not me I don't
know I no no no not true well not even
not true this is being manipulated um
and you know the level where they're
just creating phrases and the bottom
line is if anyone has the ability to
manipulate these capes like this they're
working for the NSA they don't give two
shits who's the mayor Warren Michigan of
course and this says it sounds like the
mayor to you oh no question it's
extremely clear yeah they are that
pretty good quality and they're pretty
clear I mean we're we're being
introduced to this guy for the first
time today and kind of kept herring and
contrasting his voice a little in here
the similarities so it's good it's good
to hear an expert in your opinion say
that yeah that you believe this is
definitely the same dude I'm ready well
and let's look at it from a legal
perspective okay if if Sam Roberts is
being accused publicly of saying these
things don't you have a lawyer hired
immediately to start suing the [ __ ] out
everyone yeah yeah I probably I probably
would seek legal action sure correct so
why isn't that happening here because
it's a grand canary and a great legal
defenses if something is true it's you
can't be you know you're not going to
win a lawsuit if someone's actually
putting out the lab and really speak
again right and the biggest secret in in
Macomb County politics is if you want to
pay off sue the city in a situation
where the mayor has to be deposed and
the city will settle lawsuit because
they're not going to put the mayor in
that position where you have to tell the
truth about things right the mayor is
terrified of deposition that's lam very
freely talking about this now because he
have you audacity to claim the
conspiracy and compare them self the
Martin Luther King jr. on Martin Luther
King jr. Day man oh man I only know what
you gonna do you consume me I the truth
is fine I'll suppose everyone right
you'd be had
yeah and in legal illegal surrounding
are all beautiful thank you so much man
we appreciate your candor and we're
going to keep an eye on ya we appreciate
you coming on dude thank you so much